[Música]
el día de records en américa latina
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 brasil
reportó por primera vez más de 4.000
muertos en 24 horas el estado de san
pablo
más de 1.300 nuevos casos fueron
contabilizados argentina contabiliza más
de 21.000 nuevos casos en la última
jornada ante la rápida propagación del
virus cuba también está evaluando nuevas
medidas restrictivas
la unión europea aprobó las ayudas del
gobierno francés por 4 mil 700 millones
de dólares para la aerolínea el fons de
esta forma el estado francés en recibe
el 30 por ciento del paquete accionario
de la empresa seriamente afectada por la
pandemia ya cambio también entregará
algunas de sus rutas y de sus derechos
de operación en el aeropuerto de orly de
parís
y pese a no contar con el aval de todos
los partidos políticos el presidente de
israel rubén rivlin eligió a benjamin
netanyahu como el candidato para formar
gobierno una difícil tarea dada la
polarización y los escándalos de
corrupción que pesan sobre el primer
ministro así las cosas israel enfrenta
nuevamente el fantasma de unas
elecciones generales las quintas en dos
años
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora la jornada de hoy estuvo marcada
por en la región de américa latina con
récords de muertes y de contagios por la
pandemia de kobe 19 brasil por primera
vez superó el umbral de los 4 mil
muertos solamente en un espacio de 24
horas y continúa siendo el lugar del
planeta en donde más personas mueren
debido al coronavirus entretanto
argentinas contabilizó cerca de 21 mil
nuevos casos de contagio la cifra más
alta en 24 horas desde que comenzó la
emergencia sanitaria en ese país
suramericano marina sardiña nos cuenta
más en el siguiente informe
con los cementerios desbordados este
martes brasil rompió el trágico récord
de muertes diarias por kobe 19 con 4 mil
195 fallecimientos sumando cerca de 337
mil decesos y más de 13 millones de
contagios
sao paulo el estado más desarrollado
registró un nuevo máximo con mil 389
muertes el epicentro de la pandemia en
el mundo afronta la peor fase de la
enfermedad agravada por las laxas
medidas para contener los contagios del
presidente de ultraderecha jair
bolsonaro miras las nuevas variantes del
patógeno están abrumando los hospitales
con el sistema de salud brasileño al
borde del colapso y donde la campaña de
vacunación de sus 212 millones de
habitantes avanza a un ritmo lento
apenas el 10 por ciento de la población
ha recibido la primera dosis más al sur
en argentina las autoridades sanitarias
reportaron la cifra más alta de
contagios desde el inicio de la pandemia
20 mil 870 casos positivos en 24 horas
para un total de 2,4 millones de
contagios y más de 56 mil 600 decesos en
la última semana el acelerado ritmo de
los contagios ha puesto en alerta al
país por lo que el gobierno del
presidente alberto fernández enfermó de
kobe 19 impuso
restricciones de cara a la segunda ola
del coronavirus tras un periodo
vacacional de semana santa en el que la
actividad turístico pero con aparente
normalidad ahora estamos todos muy
asustados la gente no se cuida en un
salvar dijo sal en los bares están
ajenos a cualquier horas hay boliches
así que no sé cómo está todo está
bastante mal toda la gente tiene mucho
miedo y en cuba- por octavo día
consecutivo notificó más de mil nuevos
contagios de coronavirus para un total
acumulado de 81 1640 y poco más de 400
decesos desde el inicio de la pandemia
lo llamativo es que al 1 de enero de
2021 cubas apenas registraba de otros
mil casos y se preciaba de ser un modelo
de control pero la reapertura del
aeropuerto en diciembre y la baja
percepción de riesgo ha elevado
exponencialmente los contagios el
gobierno de la isla impondrá drásticas
medidas para frenar la propagación del
virus
haití es uno de los cuatro países del
mundo que no ha comenzado a vacunar
contra el kobe 19 porque no ha adquirido
o no ha recibido algunos lotes de
vacunas sin embargo el gobierno en
puerto príncipe- declinó las vacunas de
laboratorio astrazéneca que le ofreció
la organización mundial de la salud a
través del mecanismo de solidaridad
kóvacs las autoridades haitianas han
pedido a la ms que envíe vacunas de
otros laboratorios pero el organismo
internacional no ha ofrecido otra
alternativa e indicó que se están
agotando los plazos
haití tiene logística para recibir
vacunas de astrazéneca y de johnson y
johnson pero no cuenta con sistemas de
ultra refrigeración para recibir vacunas
de la farmacéutica falsa
cambiamos de tema en chile el presidente
sebastián piñera promulgó la reforma
tras la aprobación del parlamento de
aplazar por 5 semanas las elecciones
constituyentes municipales y regionales
previstas para este fin de semana la
razón es el rápido incremento en el
número de casos de kobe 19 y también la
saturación del sistema de salud a nivel
nacional el mismo gobierno de piñera
propuso que ser ambiciosos fueran el 15
y el 16 de mayo fechas en las que 14
puntos 7 millones de chilenos están
llamados a elegir a los representantes
municipales regionales y también a los
155 delegados que redactarán la nueva
constitución de chile una de las
demandas de las protestas ciudadanas del
llamado estallido social de octubre del
cambiamos de continente nos vamos hasta
europa francia presentó una estrategia
con la que busca impulsar su plan de
vacunación masiva mientras avanza la
medida de confinamiento nacional los
estadios de fútbol y también otras
estructuras de gran tamaño pasarán a ser
llamadas vacuno dromos y se han
convertido en lugares para hacer
inmunizaciones a gran escala junto a los
hospitales militares que también han
sido puestos a disposición de las
autoridades sanitarias con esta medida
el gobierno espera inocular a la mitad
de los ciudadanos para mediados de este
año
inyección de esperanza en francia en
medio del tercer confinamiento en un año
el elíseo pretende revertir la grave
situación epidemiológica del país con un
plan masivo de vacunación para ello
algunos campos de fútbol y otras
infraestructuras se han convertido en
vacuno dromos como el stade france el
estadio de la selección francesa situado
en la periferia norte de parís en el
departamento de seine saint denis una
zona al borde del colapso hospitalario
nuestro objetivo es tener aquí a 50
personas continuamente que atiendan a
los habitantes de sense and them y que
pidan cita por teléfono la previsión es
que durante al menos seis meses en el
estado de france se inoculen cien mil
dosis de vacunas contra el cob y 19 cada
semana y que abrían la vacuna aquí en el
estadio de francia y esto nos permitirá
volver a tener libertad ayer bien la
tarde por televisión que uno podía pedir
cita y logré una para hoy a las 10 de la
mañana pero más allá del estado de
france hay otros 15 mega centros de
vacunación operativos
el país y la intención del gobierno es
llegar a 46 a finales de abril la
estrategia masiva de vacunación
comprende la integración de los 8
hospitales militares que hay en francia
en total el ejecutivo francés pretende
haber vacunado a 30 millones de personas
es decir a la mitad de su población a
mediados de junio fue mi médico quien me
prescribió la vacuna me dijo que la de
facer estaría disponible a final de
marzo así que esperaba
sin embargo a pesar de que francia sea
uno de los países europeos con más y más
largas restricciones para frenar la
pandemia su población es de las más
escépticas del mundo frente a las
vacunas la unión europea aprobó ayudas
gubernamentales por unos 4.700 millones
de dólares para la aerolínea francesa
iphones seriamente afectada por la
pandemia del cob y 19 pero este préstamo
tiene condiciones
la aerolínea comprometió algunos de los
'slots' --derechos de aterrizaje que son
esos derechos de aterrizaje servicio y
despegue para los aeropuertos en este
caso el aeropuerto de orly en parís
asimismo el estado francés recibirá el
30 por ciento del paquete accionario del
grupo air france que también compromete
a otras aerolíneas como hop city jet y
las neerlandesas klm y transavia para
realizar este tema saludamos a ricardo
del piano él es analista de transporte
aéreo se encuentra en la ciudad de
santiago en chile y nos va a ayudar a
analizar y entender un poco esta
transacción ricardo gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 y esta
estrategia que compromete el 30 por
ciento del paquete accionario que ahora
pasará al
francés en que se traduce para ayudar a
la aerolínea nacional a fons buenas
tardes de santiago un gusto nuevamente
estaba compartiendo acá y bueno primer
primer lugar que sin duda es una es una
medida para compensar todo lo que está
afectando la crisis de sobre todo en
este tercer confinamiento duro
confinamiento acompañar a la compañía
del transporte a ellos en particular el
funk el francés hay que recordar que la
principal línea aérea de francia y que
mueve gran parte y por tanto es un
importante actor no sólo para la
industria del transporte aéreo y el
turismo francés sino a nivel de la
economía general genera una serie de
aportes que tiene sentido las ayudas de
directamente se interpretan como una
forma de compensar y ayudar el plan el
plan de sostenibilidad y transformación
de la empresa y ayudar a sortear la
crisis que por lo menos al menos en el
primer semestre del 2021 va a continuar
sea parcialmente afectada ricardo porque
esta estrategia es diferente porque en
el pasado vimos que por ejemplo la
aerolínea nacional de hungría mal efe
recibió préstamos por parte del estado
la comisión europea luego dijo que no
era
que no era válido tuvo que devolver ese
dinero y declararse en bancarrota vemos
el drama que tiene al italia con sus
inversionistas privados y con el estado
también en portugal está portugal a
tuvieron que vender a manos privadas
porque en este caso la comisión si avala
este 30 por ciento de estos cuatro mil
700 millones de dólares para el franz
pero hay un análisis previo en ese
sentido hay un reconocimiento a la labor
que air france ha hecho en forma de
avanzar en sostenibilidad no sólo como
compañía aérea y en presentar un plan de
estuve un negocio sustentable en
precisamente la llegada del 2020 mittal
al gobierno de fans apunta a generar una
empresa sustentable en el tiempo y la
compañía de hecho numerosas
transformaciones que va a continuar
y ha establecido una serie de compromiso
en esa línea y por tanto avalan todo le
dan garantías al estado francés ya la
comisión europea la unión europea en
entregarle ayuda a cosas que no ha
ocurrido con una diaria como menciona a
la italia que es en una casa muy
complicado donde todavía nos vemos nos
ve que ya aparte arrastra bastante una
serie de ayudas
que están todavía en investigación hay
que aclarar ese punto y bueno hasta
portugal y el caso de que venían con
fuertes pasivos que también le
determinaron cerrando como recibe
entonces la competencia porque air
france no es la única aerolínea en el
mercado francés para recibir todos estos
dineros la ayuda del estado esto cae mal
sin duda alguna la competencia que hacer
entonces para igualdad
allí la balanza la gestión de los slots
que sólo derechos de aterrizaje y
despegue aterrizaje es la mejor fue una
forma de cómo ayudar a la competencia
los sin duda que cada vez por ser de
horas con otras líneas que operan en él
y se van a ver beneficiadas porque van a
poder incrementar capacidad con la
salida de fans que tiene domina gran
parte de este aeropuerto ahora para el
francés compromete también la favorece
porque va a poder concentrar sus
operaciones en un solo aeropuerto como
estar de bolt y mientras dejando el
resto de la competencia en el en orly lo
local en más barras debajo de ser mucho
a la industria aérea de la francesa el
cargo del piano desde la ciudad de
santiago en chile muchas gracias por
analizar este tema para nuestra
audiencia quien france24
de tema este martes el presidente de
israel rubén ripley encargó al primer
ministro en funciones benjamin netanyahu
la formación de un nuevo gobierno pese a
que éste no contaba con el favoritismo
por parte de algunos partidos políticos
dada la fragmentación parlamentaria y
también los casos de corrupción que
están persiguiendo a netanyahu no será
fácil que logre conformar una nueva
coalición de gobierno que saque israel
de ese bloqueo político por lo que el
país estaría nuevamente ante la
posibilidad de unas quintas elecciones
en solamente dos años rodrigo sedano nos
cuenta más en el siguiente informe
una decisión que no fue fácil ni ética
ni moralmente de esta forma anunció el
presidente de israel reuvén rivlin el
encargo a benjamin netanyahu de la
formación de un nuevo gobierno no está
claro que netanyahu vaya a conseguir los
apoyos necesarios pero la alternativa
serían unas quintas elecciones en menos
de dos años y báltica
he tomado una decisión basada en el
número de recomendaciones que indican
que en miembro de la canna set benjamin
netanyahu tiene ligeramente más opciones
de formar gobierno por ello he decidido
confiar en la tarea de hacerlo
sola las elecciones del pasado 23 de
marzo dejaron un parlamento ampliamente
fragmentado que sin embargo se divide en
dos bloques principales a favor y en
contra de netanyahu ninguno de los dos
obtendría la mayoría absoluta de 61
escaños para formar gobierno y
paradójicamente el partido árabe
islamista raam con cuatro escaños podría
tener la llave del futuro político de
israel
existe la posibilidad de que les veamos
formar parte de algún tipo de coalición
que netanyahu e intente formar pero no
existe la posibilidad que los apoyen
desde fuera del gobierno
en otras palabras será un gobierno en
minoría la posibilidad es real dada la
idiosincrasia de este partido expulsado
de la lista conjunta de partidos árabes
por su apertura a trabajar con netanyahu
para defender los intereses de la
minoría árabe pero los casos de
corrupción que persiguen al presidente
en funciones no harán fácil la tarea
este martes netanyahu se enfrenta
también a la segunda audiencia de la
fase probatoria del juicio que comenzó
ayer a ball motion also con lo que está
pasando es un esfuerzo para trampear la
democracia de los siglos boletus están
intentando anular los deseos del
electorado
un argumento que recuerda el del ex
presidente estadounidense donald trump
para no perder la presidencia los
próximos días decidirán si netanyahu
corre la misma suerte que su ex aliado
en la casa blanca
es todo por el momento en las noticias
en nombre del equipo de france 24
gracias por la sintonía más información
en france 24 punto com en las redes
sociales y en la app buenas noches
[Música]